our big sit-down interview with Brittany
commisso one of the 11 women who claimed
that New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
sexually harassed them and it comes as
the three-term Democrat faces a new
crisis this morning after his top aide
Melissa DeRosa announced she's resigning
and state legislators plan to meet today
to discuss their impeachment
investigation we should point out at the
top here that Cuomo denies all
allegations of misconduct and rejected
new calls for his resignation after a
scathing report from the state's
attorney general commisso identified as
executive assistant number one in the
AG's report has filed the first criminal
complaint against Cuomo in an exclusive
interview with CBS This Morning in
albany's time Union newspaper camiso
says the governor gave her intimate hugs
and kisses people were these were not
hugs that he would give
his mother or you know his brother these
were hugs with the intention of getting
some personal
sexual satisfaction out of then they
started to be hugs with kisses on the
cheek and then there was at one point a
hug and then when he went to go kiss me
on the cheek he'd quickly turned his
head and he kissed me on the lips what
did you say I didn't say anything
I didn't say anything this whole time
people don't understand
that this is the governor of the state
of New York there are Troopers that are
outside of the Mansion they are not
there to protect me they are there to
protect him
I felt as though if I did something to
insult him especially insult him in his
own home it wasn't going to be him that
was going to get
fired or in trouble did you ever have
any consensual sexual activity with the
governor of New York State no is it
possible that the governor thought that
these interactions that he was having
with you was something that was normal
something that he thought was not a big
deal no
maybe to him
that he thought this was normal but to
me and the other women that he did this
to it was not normal
it was not welcomed
and it was certainly not consensual
the governor testified that he did not
kiss executive assistant number one
we'll have more on our exclusive
conversation with Brittany commisso
coming up on CBS This Morning